you just raise 15 million dollars at a
billion dollar valuation
which my math's not always perfect but i
think that's one percent or so 1.5
i thought when you hit that unicorn
status you would raise 150 and dilute 10
percent
why raise 15 million are you pegasus
you're being super frugal
what's even the point of racing 15 when
you're at a billion dollar evaluation we
are
quite frugal uh profitable or close
we are most of the money we spend comes
from customers let's
let's put it put it like spinning
distance if you wanted to be profitable
you could
if we weren't investing as heavily in r
d we we could yeah
um so back to the question why raise 15
you go out and raise money why not raise
a hundred the big reason for that round
um was actually to get uh jeff emil the
former
ceo of ge involved in form labs uh so he
he uh he's a venture partner at nea and
um and a woman named dana grayson at nea
actually she's starting her own fun now
uh she led the round and and jeff joined
the board
i thought that they were those type of
big firms what you hear
on the streets is they need to have 10
ownership they need to be
able to put in 50 million checks it's
not worth it
how do you convince somebody because
nea's got multiple billions of dollars
in their funds how do you get them to
write such a small check
and have such a small ownership
percentage was that an issue and why do
we hear that issue constantly
um yeah it's definitely a point you
negotiate on i think they have their
their business model where they sort of
have a target investment
but every company is different every
situation is different so there's always
some some flexibility there
and we had just raised um 35 million
dollars a few months before that so
it's kind of a 50 million dollar round
so it's a little top off at
that valuation and then how do you look
at this
business now that you're in you're
you're getting close to that decade
people expect it to go public
or have an exit and you're raising at a
billion
you know we just saw masayoshi-san and
softbank kind of back off a little bit
of like some of these later stage rounds
and people are generally questioning
like
is it a good idea to stay private that
long what kind of
advice are you getting in this sort of
roller coaster of the industry changing
from
growth at all costs go big stay private
to get profitable
and how do you think about it personally
and how you want to live as a founder
we've always been a very
disciplined company that's that's
focused on
uh again most of the money we spend
coming from customers rather than
burning lots of investor capital we
that's been true since
basically like year one we launched
kickstarter we got started end of 2011
and by the end of 2012 we had taken
three million in pre-orders
um and with you know less than two
million inequity raised
wow so uh so we've been selling stuff
and trying to build our business
maybe not organically but trying to
build it sort of sustainably
from the beginning and um i think uh i
think that's the right way to do it in
this industry
they're certainly like you know if
you're building a consumer web thing
where
a scale really matters and network
effects really matter
like maybe it makes sense to lose a
billion dollars before you
you know start advertising yeah piss
everybody off
and i think one of the really big
mistakes that that's happened in
uh uh venture capital in the last couple
years is that
the people have assumed that model could
be applied to a lot of other industries
where it just doesn't work and you end
up all that money you burn doesn't
actually get you
some value that stays like it might have
helped drive some revenue but not
in a in a very sticky sustainable way
yeah investing to have
a billion people on facebook or a
hundred million people using snapchat
we pretty much know how the advertising
world works you can pretty much model it
but if you're doing something new like
uber or lyft
and or doordash and ubereats or whatever
it is like
yeah yeah do do we know that losing all
this money makes sense or not
and the public market seems to think not
subsidizing rides for years and years
and years it's unclear
like what value is left today whereas
for us
when the money that we're losing is
primarily going into
investing more heavily in r d and you
know after a few years of r d we have a
very clear
thing left over which is a product that
we're selling which is better than you
know what exists out there so
i think we're we try to stay disciplined
we don't try to lose
you know when we're selling in terms of
sales and marketing activities we make
sure we don't lose money there because
that just doesn't make sense
uh and then how do you think about from
this point forward
because that's the big question today
should you go public should you stay
private and
you're kind of at that point where it
used to be when you hit 25 50 million in
revenue you went public you're over 100
million in revenue now
are you feeling pressure to go public or
exit because you got boston-based
company like they're not used to 100
billion dollar companies they
they probably very much would appreciate
a quick you're right into 5 billion
you're right a lot of boston investors
are not used to that sort of thing which
is probably why we have very few
boston exactly no offense to boston
investors but they do
they are scary there's some great there
are a few great ones there but they're
scared
a lot of them are scared yeah all
downside protection
yeah and so we uh we have ended up with
more bay area
investors um so
uh yeah so how do you think about that
yeah i think file or you think you're
gonna just
stay private for me in terms of like my
personal goals and i think
um also reflect what most of the people
at the company are interested in
going public or staying private is sort
of orthogonal to the goal the goal is
build more awesome stuff and get it to
lots of people and make an impact with
that
and do that at a bigger scale make more
products get them to more people
and keep keep going there um you get the
reality whether we are pressuring you a
bit like hey we gotta do something
so the good thing is we do have these
really long-term focused investors
there's not uh you know not a huge
pressure there as long as we're growing
and
and uh and making progress then you know
they have they have the ability to wait
um and i think
board and investors are aligned that
like uh
you know going public has to to to make
sense for
for the company doing it too early it's
a huge overhead and a huge distraction
if a company can't show kind of really
uh
regular predictable uh revenue and you
feel you have predictive revenue hours
is the industry still emerging and
you're still figuring it out
i i think we shouldn't be going public
today yeah
i mean it goes back to the sort of
opening of the show when i was talking
about hey
how predictable is it you're still in
that point of time we
you know maybe dental's the entire
business maybe there's an entire
business just on dental globally
you know and like that's a hard decision
for you to make as a founder who loves
3d printing right like
if you're just going for the ipo then
logic might say just pick the one
vertical that works best
and ignore everything else and just be a
dental company
and i think a lot of our success has
been actually avoiding that
trend that's a lot of the advice we've
received a lot of the sort of like
classic
advice for a b2b company is sort of to
like pick
one vertical and focus on and specialize
in it
and that i think is how a lot of the
existing 3d printing companies have been
built up
they're not always just focused on one
vertical but they sort of align their
products and
and their go to market and everything
around that and they've missed the
opportunity to do this
broad-based investment in in one
technology platform
where if we actually put even though we
are not one of the bigger companies in
the industry
we put more r d into a single printer
model than anyone else and that's part
of how we deliver
much more printer per dollar than anyone
else it's sort of
you know apple is kind of the the best
example of this where
they have less skus than companies with
far less revenue than them
yeah and so they get to invest so much
in making every single product they make
the best by far yeah when you look at
airpods it's like there's
a hundred knockoffs on amazon right now
and just in terms of elegance and
you know what just works yeah the the
airpods work the best
but it is interesting the knockoff